I've met an old acquaintance of yours
um Jerry Harrison uh and bumped into him
a couple of times
and told him how much Talking Heads
meant to me uh meant so much to me thank
you and I have a very clear crystal
clear memory
of
I would have been I want to say maybe
1983 84 somewhere around there I'm in
college
and of course I'm obsessed with late
night with David Letterman and he has
you guys on
and you play Burning Down The House on
Letterman and it was my whole world of
things that I loved coming together in
one moment which rarely happened when
you're at that phase it was so there was
much less entertainment back then so the
fact that I remembered I think Dave
chatted with you uh a bit you you came
over to the interview chair either
before or after the song and he was
talking to you and I thought this is
everything I like in life in one place
at the same time I remember uh well I've
seen
kind of replays of that chat it seemed
like a very uh it was a very odd chat it
was
um I was very nervous
um and
they were fairly stilted answers but I
don't think I remembered watching it and
having no judgment about it which is
just that's you this is Dave I don't you
know this this is what's happening at
this moment I loved the performance uh
of the song you know and uh
uh you know so fascinated by
you know talking about the beginnings of
that band I never realized until
recently that psycho killer which is the
first big hit was the only the second
song you had ever written yeah yeah it
was kind of an experiment to see can I
can I really write a song wow I got help
from some of the others uh
but
we did and people seem to like that one
yeah and then I thought oh it also
sounded so different uh from anything
else at the time to me it just was so it
was
um and and I know that you were trying
to I read an interview once where you
said in Psycho Killer you were trying to
um almost as a thought experiment saying
what if Alice Cooper and Randy Newman
wrote a song together exactly yes
what a fantastic first of all who
approaches songwriting with that kind of
idea
I liked them both yeah well you know you
like it both both it's like cooking put
them together I like onions I like ice
cream they must be good together
uh did you
um I'm curious you so you wrote that
song and things start to take off and
then you just have this phenomenal
success and I I think the rare thing
that you guys pulled off was
the group was very commercially
successful it was the soundtrack for a
lot of people of late 70s early 80s but
also very highly regarded and respected
at the same time which doesn't always
happen
it doesn't always happen
um
we were
kind of determined to do what we did but
I think we're also pretty lucky at that
be around at that time where that kind
of thing was accepted there's a certain
amount of luck involved yeah I like it
when people acknowledge luck I mean yeah
or we were in back at cbgb's we were
kind of in the right place at the right
time
other bands were playing people were
coming to see them record companies
coming to see them
um we didn't plan that hey Sona think of
all the amazing things in life that are
expressions of just you yeah I mean like
the chocolate that you had on your face
when you came in because you just ate
that what was it you were eating I was
eating a giant cookie giant cookie yeah
and that's so Sona okay or that song you
stream over and over again it's just so
you what's that song For You Twinkle
Twinkle Little Star yeah but it's for my
boys I know still it's nice okay or you
know that podcast that comedy podcast
you just gotta listen to yeah Conan
O'Brien needs a friend exactly is that
what you listen to in your spare time
yeah I love it everything that makes you
you may oh all the difference State Farm
believes Insurance should work the same
way your plan your coverage selections
could be personalized by you and only
you that's cool I shouldn't shout but
this is how strong away I feel about it
you go to choose the plan you want by
picking the options to fit you like
choosing to bundle your home and auto
policies is what the State Farm personal
price plan is all about getting the
coverage you want at an affordable price
just for you call or go to statefarm.com
today to create your State Farm personal
price plan prices vary by state options
selected by customers availability and
eligibility may vary if you ever think
to yourself I do in comedy and think
what if I was starting now
how would you do what would you do what
would I do if I started now how would I
because there's so much out there how
would I how would I make it and I'm not
sure that I would
um I'm very lucky so much yeah
there's a lot of music out there too yes
yeah um
the streaming services and everything
everywhere are just filled filled filled
with music and you wonder how
the I still find lots of things that I
like but I can imagine for a lot of
people it's like well it's just too much
right I think that your people are
overwhelmed and then they get siled I
just want to listen to these three it's
you're not uh just as in news you don't
have to hear an opinion you don't want
to hear anymore because you can just
watch your the same thing is happening I
think in music and in comedy you can
just seek out these are the seven things
that give me Comfort
and you will not run into anything that
might challenge you which is kind of
scary
it makes you think uh
I mean at that time
um
when you're there's such a nice
Evolution too with your with your band
with Talking Heads that the music kept
evolving it didn't it felt like
if I'm if I'm not mistaken there was a
determination to not do the same thing
twice exactly and I'd grown up
as a music fan in the late 60s early 70s
who did you like oh you know I liked the
Temptations and James Brown and the
Beatles And The Rolling Stones and The
Who and you know
everything all these acts that were
around and a lot of them not all of them
but a lot of them
would CH from album to album they'd
evolve yeah do different things and try
these odd adding these odd sounds and
Odd Ideas into their songs and I thought
that's what you do you can get away with
it yeah yeah and look they're successful
and so I thought well okay if they can
do it that's the
that's that's the way to go if you can
get it get away with it
was there pressure after psycho killer
from record label to say like that was
great do that again
because you didn't
uh there was probably pressure after
some other things like maybe
maybe when we did some successful tours
or something like that it was more like
that's good you're doing good just stay
on the road yep and that can be fun but
kind of deadly after a while yeah uh
famously the road it
um it in my limited experience with it
it is thrilling for what for just a
little while and then you see
you understand why people become addicts
and alcoholics you know and uh because
you're on a bus and uh you're you're
really amped up after a show and you
want to come down from after a show and
then it's time to get on a bus and it's
it's not a good Rhythm to live in
consistently yeah you just watch some
movies and start drinking yeah
uh
I mean I do that now but I'm not even
touring so this is
I'm realizing now this is an
intervention they've called it
I've got no